à noël pour un anniversaire ou la saint
valentin c'est le cadeau classique mais
qui fait toujours plaisir
le parfum capiteux léger résolument
viril ou floral il y en a pour tous les
goûts il en sort 500 nouveaux chaque
année les français en sont complètement
fans ils dépensent plus de 2 milliards
d'euros par an celle arme de séduction
massive
ouais c'est indispensable si je suis pas
parfait mais le matin je ne peux pas
aller travailler
moi je suis plus à le petit cadeau quoi
je le laisse là
petit indice tiens j'ai bientôt finies
ou parfois rennes on attend déjà l'avant
ça coûte cher
oui mais j'ai une odeur naturelle très
agréable et j'ai jamais eu besoin de me
parfumer honnêtement un peu d'autres
colonnes quelquefois quand les cheveux
s'envole pour les re plaquer mais ce
tour mais derrière un parfum il ya
toujours un homme ou plutôt un nez pour
savoir comment sont inventé ces
fragrances qui se vendent dans le monde
entier nous avons suivi thierry wasser
l'un des meilleurs de sa génération mais
vous allez voir qu'il existe même une
école pour devenir parfumeurs
professionnels et cannes et ça ne sert
pas qu'à crée des parfums
on en a aussi besoin de vous rendre plus
agréable certains produits de notre vie
très quotidienne cette semaine combien
ça coûte l'hebdo vous tient aux parfums
thierry wasser fait le métier que tout
le monde un jour rêvé de faire thierry
aînés ils inventent des parfums il fait
même partie des 10 meilleurs au monde
dior addict c'est lui hypnose de lancôme
encore lui et diesel femme toujours lui
depuis deux ans thierry le nez attitré
de guerlain le plus vieux parfumeur
français et aujourd'hui il a la pression
idylle le premier parfum qui l'a mise au
point pendant un an et qui vient d'être
lancée à grands frais doit passer un
test très important
la saint valentin la fête des amoureux
par excellence
pour moi c'est le lancement est un
moment émouvant je vous dis avec un peu
d'appréhension aussi parce qu'on sait
jamais comment nous comment le parfum va
être reçue et la concurrence est rude
cinq cents nouvelles fragrances sortent
chaque année
alors pour savoir si son parfum va
plaire puisque je suis la syrie a un
truc il se fait passer pour un vendeur
et musiques et photos bull la languette
la première impression se doit d'être la
bonne un consommateur se décide en 30
secondes
je chante c'est là que j'apprends c'est
en vous voyant surtout si vous avez
mieux parce que c'est beaucoup plus
drôle
ce parfum s'est déjà classé dans le top
10 des meilleures ventes
le problème justement c'est que tout le
monde porte les mêmes mais ici il existe
un service unique
alors voilà le salon où je reçois mes
clientes pour les barrages sur mesure
avoir son parfum rien qu'à soi qui
n'existe qu'en un seul exemplaire au
monde c'est possible mais ils ne sont
qu'une poignée à pouvoir se l'offrir
c'est un coup de 32000 rosereau 35000 je
n'aime plus le prix à payer pour
s'attacher les services de thierry
pendant un an et avoir le droit à deux
litres de parfums direction l'usiné de
la marque à orphin dans les yvelines
chaque année 650 mille litres de parfums
sorte d'ici dans ce milieu où les
secrets de fabrication sont jalousement
et férocement garder même les ouvriers
qui travaillent à la chaîne ignore la
composition exacte des parfums
seules deux personnes connaissent les
formules secrètes et lé dosage précis
c'est jean paul guerlain bien sûr est
celui qui l'a choisi comme son
successeur thierry wasser le trésor de
guerre du parfumeur se trouve dans le
coffre fort de leur bureau en permanence
sous leur nez
je vous montrerai pas la formule du
jeune jack wills shalimar non dans ce
manuscrit les secrets industriels des
700 parfum créé en 180 ans d'existence
et j'aimerais bien qu'à quatre pattes
devant le coffre
et si thierry a accès au coffre fort
c'est parce qu'il est un et comme il y
en a peu il peut reconnaître jusqu'à
trois mille odeurs différentes
ce matin thierry vient de recevoir de la
vanille de madagascar spécialement
sélectionnés pour lui il y en a dans
presque tous les parfums seller piste la
plus chère au monde après le safran il
doit en faire de la teinture de vanille
qui ne servira pas tout de suite mais
dans quelques années
il faut imaginer ce que cette qualité
pourrait donner avec les années
années de maturation et de macération
dans l'alcool faut attendre au moins
trois cas transport de ces matières
premières enfermés dans ces grosses
cuves c'est la richesse d'un parfumeur
pour le dernier né de thierry wasser la
maison a dépensé plus d'un million
d'euros rien que pour acheter des rose
de bulgarie paulo le responsable du
stock est assis sur un tas d'or
on a 150 tubes comme celle ci je ne peux
même pas vous parler de prix de matières
premières
c'est tellement aléatoire et ça peut
vous paraître tellement soit démesurée
démentiel utopique même que je pense que
ça n'a pas de sens un parfum qui marche
doit rembourser la dizaine de millions
d'euros d'investissement dès sa première
année de lancement
et dans ce domaine les français sont les
leaders incontestés
à grasse la capitale du parfum plus de
60 entreprises et 3000 personnes
travaillent dans cette industrie
tout le monde ici et parfums dépendants
et depuis peu il existe même une école
pour devenir nez pascal est une ancienne
pharmacienne et à 40 ans elle a décidé
de changer de métier dernier petit café
avant il n'existe qu'une petite centaine
d'années en france
pascal a investi toutes ses économies
dans l'espoir d'en faire un jour partie
l'école plus le logement c'est à peu
près 1500 euros par mois un
investissement important mais à la fin
de l'année je pense que j'aurai un
travail merveilleux entre les mains ce
métier fait rêver et c'est tenait à
cadets me reçoit plus d'une centaine de
candidatures mais seulement une douzaine
de dossiers sont retenus des élèves qui
viennent d'inde de russie ou du japon
prêts à débourser 11 mille euros pour
suivre une formation intensive
ils n'ont aucun don particulier
guatemala notes from india devenir
nécessaire juste du travail ils doivent
apprendre à mémoriser les 300 odeurs
basique qui composent la grande majorité
des parfums même un parfumeur qui a 30
ans d'expérience peut pas rester sans
réviser c'est pareil quand un score si
vous vous entraînez pas vous avez pas de
résultats 1 et peut gagner entre 2000
euros pour un débutant et 10000 euros
pour les meilleurs mais la plupart de
ces étudiants ne travaillerons peut-être
jamais pour la parfumerie de luxe dans
cette société par exemple 12 néo travail
à plein temps pour parfumer la lessive
le shampoing ou même le détergent que
l'on achète au supermarché parfum ou
nouveau savon à lancer de toute façon ça
commence toujours par un petit bout de
papier
on appelle ça le bris on reste toujours
100% d'origine naturelle c'est une gamme
bio donc avec les mêmes caractéristiques
que les précédentes qui ont fait succès
talent ce sont les indications du client
fraîcheur nature bio trois mots avec
lesquels philippe et son équipe doivent
créer le nouveau parfum d'un gel douche
ou la saint jean du pin sens pour moi ça
va pas marcher
ce n'est pas la seule société en
compétition et si le rôdeur n'est pas
retenue ils en seront pour leur argent
il ya des projets qui vont durer 18 mois
et où vous sortez de marni ans père du
projet vous avez travaillé pour guy malé
pas de compensation financière
s'il courte même le risque c'est que
s'ils emportent le morceau ça peut être
le jackpot
ils seront les seuls propriétaires de la
formule cette maison de composition
travail pour les plus grandes marques et
elle s'est même équipé de plusieurs
salles de bain pour pouvoir tester les
savons liquides vaisselle ou autres
désodorisants pour toilettes
comme quoi finalement l'argent a
peut-être bien une odeur